foreign
good morning good evening wherever you
are in the world and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel we are in we have Matty say
hello Matty hello
and we have Young Harris over there
looking there looking tired looking like
he's looking like he had a really good
New Year's Eve rightfully so howdy howdy
yeah I'm all right
so we won't
tease you for too long but
run the credits
[Music]
okay so today we were going to be doing
a video welcoming 2023 and telling you
all about the projects we were looking
forward to including hopefully
Stargate and bringing back our a lot of
our favorite sci-fi show
as you guys know
Paul ghostby and Mark fergus's
production company penguin and Parker
um a couple of months ago now asked
Amazon or Amazon asking what would you
like to do and they said we would love
to do Stargate and Stargate were like
well that's funny we'd quite like to do
Stargate too
so they started doing some developments
in their system development work and
then I broke the news a couple of weeks
ago that they had actually started some
contract negotiations which was all very
exciting we weren't quite sure whether
they were going to be show running or
what but
um at very least they're developing
I had some news today a message that
started with oh by the way did I tell
you which is always good
and the Before Christmas the contract
negotiations between penguin in a park
and Amazon collapsed
um that there were several issues that
penguin and Parker and Amazon disagreed
on
um and
at the moment even though the deal isn't
dead because they do have a good working
relationship it's not looking amazing
so we could actually be back to square
one
before I explain to you what those
issues were just because you guys don't
know this I haven't told you I only
literally found out today so I've been
scrambling around trying to find out as
much information as I could before we
went live
um
instant thoughts
[ __ ] yep that was nice I said something
more colorful
what went wrong what they'd done all
that work what could possibly have gone
wrong is it due to God of War or what
you know it looks like God of War was
part of the issue so apparently there
was there was three or four things that
happened so initially
um the God of War deal was thing but the
God of War deal has been known about for
like six months so that that wasn't a
major problem but as soon as the God of
War deal sort of was signed and they
started doing all the work a couple of
people at Amazon did apparently raise
the question of is penguin the Parker
big enough
do they have enough experience whatever
to do both of these big projects because
apparently they want God of War to be a
big project they're looking at like 12
million dollars an episode average for
God of War which I was just like what
um that's more than what starts with the
massive franchise in gimming
yeah so they want to make that into a
big franchise apparently so there was
questions about that but Mark Fergus
sort of said well look I'm running
Stargate that was my baby I really
wanted to Stargate Hawk best name ever
um is really pushing God of War that's
his baby so his Focus will be there my
focus will be here this is what we've
done before when we did the expanse we
ran lots of different projects so that
was a question but didn't really
cause an issue
then they started negotiating about time
frames and apparently they want God of
War filming
um within like a few months they're
looking at like spring
um and
penguin and Parker sort of went
[ __ ] really and that that's gonna be
that that's that's a little closer than
we thought so that caused a bit of an
issue but apparently these things like
normal negotiation stuff that goes on
you know the executives always want the
impossible don't they they always want
that well can we have this on our
screens next week and then the actual
guys make me have to sort of go it might
be a little tricky
um but you know you negotiate while you
you've got the contracts didn't you
the big Thorn that apparently there is a
big meeting between Mark Fergus and oh
[ __ ] I didn't write his name down
the chief executive at um Amazon is I'll
find out his name in a bit
um there's a big meeting between those
two guys anyway and they started
actually talking about the plan for the
show
first thing the first major problem was
Amazon told MGM that they said we're
going to put this on Amazon Plus
in America and the rest of the world
which Mark Fergus immediately went
that's not what we said before
apparently
um
according to my source the agreement was
it would go on MGM Plus in America
and Prime everywhere else
um so Mark Fergus wasn't happy about
that
then they told them because it's going
on a smaller platform the budget's going
to be smaller
and apparently
Mark Fergus was suggesting that his
project was going to require around 10
million dollars an episode average
so some would be more some would be less
but 10 episodes roughly would cost 100
million dollars
um they came back with uh 50 million
dollars
is is the most we're willing to pay for
a new project on
um MGM Plus
that was the hurdle that
apparently Mark figures just went that's
not possible it can't be done
you'd think with a brand new streaming
platform they'd put more money into it
to have a bigger and better show so that
that show could
pave the way for more content in the
future they want to start with the bang
Les
no that doesn't show confidence in it I
don't think that doesn't show confidence
in Stargate at all
right yeah
um the other biggest show on MGM plus
right now it's still epics at the moment
is
um uh Billy the Kid that averages three
million dollars an episode
it's a completely different sort of
project because it's
you know um it's
um cowboy and Western thing isn't
there's no special effects really
there's this don't work much about it
but
it would still be the most expensive
project apparently on MGM Plus
the post-production itself should be
three million dollars an episode or a
million and a half two million an
episode minimum
I say I think I think it was just like
really quick
shouldn't have hopes up
um
and about yeah the Stargate the Stargate
franchise is huge and to me
it's just it's just crazy
William Arden's the stock Adventures
become a fumbled football between the
various corporate factions a little
chance of crossing the Gold Line
what's your I'm going to tell you what
my instinct about this is and I'm I'm
I'm I'm worried I won't lie but what is
your instinct about whether stargate's
gonna happen based on this
I think it'll happen
it's just gonna it's gonna take some
time I think honestly they have to
figure out what their game plan is this
does not show confidence in any bit of
the franchise at all which is not
very nice to of all of us Stargate fans
who they just took it off Amazon Prime
to dangle the freaking carrot in front
of our faces to go over to epics and
then they're not even gonna go forward
with anything uh obviously
talks go down over time but to actively
be willing to toy with the third largest
side five fan base on this planet
arguably
the sleeping giant you know as we like
to say it's it's it's not fair for all
the people that have put their time and
effort into making the series in the
past 20 years and it's not time it's not
fair for all the people that want to and
are actively looking for more of it and
instead of getting more of it they're
being toyed with yeah it's a Care on a
treadmill or a piece of cake on a
treadmill and you're just running after
nothing really
how about you man
you can tell how like no there's no
energy in the room now she's like I know
what the [ __ ] sake I came into this
live show all pumped up like yeah let's
talk about 2023 and you just ruined my
we've ruined my day
right
Stargate back in the day
had a really really low budget anyway
they pulled together a fantastic show
out of basically nothing yeah
stock has always been sg1 had nearly a
million dollars an episode Back Then
yeah well I mean they they had their
budget cut at one point so they had to
they had to do um
workarounds and all this stuff
I'm kind of in the mindset maybe they'll
just try and do that again they'll do a
work around and it will still be good
because a lot of a lot of shows that
come out on a shoestring budget still
actually are really good money isn't
everything
but
what like I said apparently how this
meeting ended was Mark Fergus politely
saying we can't do that
and basically saying we'll talk again in
the new year
um which was not what was supposed to
happen this was actually supposed to be
we're announcing this mid-January
um
crack on sort of thing
so I don't think it's dead and they have
a good working relationship with Amazon
so we shouldn't just let go well that's
going to walk away
the bit that concerns me is this news
we're hearing about Bad Robot
and I've heard that you know there are
potentially negotiations going on there
we now I was told by my source who does
work reasonably close to this and so
didn't didn't just say this person
couldn't tell me all the information
because they didn't actually have it in
their hands
they saw something
and they believed it was more to do with
a movie potentially but
we don't know maybe that is kicked off
because Mark Fergus has said
we can't do that so Amazon has gone well
bad robots ready to crack on and they
can so here we go I mean that's me
speculating that's me spitballing
completely but yeah
it might just mean if Bad Robot we're
going to be doing uh the movie side of
things
that we just get the movie first
the movie franchise kicks it all off and
hopefully Hawk and Mark and
they can they can they can work
something out so in in the intermediary
period they can bring a show after the
movie
I'd like to think so oh sorry that was
one of the things they said apparently
there was negotiating about the movie as
well and Mark Fergus was always told
apparently that the movie in the series
would go hand in hand and then during
this meeting they were told no it's
going to be a standalone so the movie
would be standalone
um and things like apparently Marco's
didn't really like that either he
thought he was going to have rain over
the whole franchise than it turned out
no he's not maybe so um
don't know
doesn't follow on
sorry gone house no I said at that point
you might as well ask what is Canon if
they're separating the two and I we just
don't need to get into that conversation
with Stargate it's screwed Star Trek
Star Wars completely over and and that's
what we want to emulate you know let's
not emulate that if we don't have to
it's that's something obviously
who's the people that screwed him up
both times too
Stargate is big enough though that you
can have individual stories in a
90-minute movie and it not as long as it
sticks within Canon and it not interfere
with the TV series I don't have any
issue with that
[Music]
um
it's just like like all the stuff I've
been hearing for months has always been
it'll be in Canon they're going to do a
Marvel style
thing where all of the movies and
they'll interlock with each other and
then all of a sudden sort of like yeah
I've changed their minds
and I wonder if that's because Bad Robot
have come with an idea and started going
yeah let's
we'll do that then it's completely
[ __ ] different but
and it'll be a parallel universe
nonsense
or something but again I don't know for
sure but
is making a parallel universe but it's
such a cop-out like everyone does that
yeah it's it's lazy as far as I'm
concerned
um I will go back to the room where I
heard months ago as well and I'd like
say I did say at the time I was told by
a guy that works
and that only tells you too much
information then the lives are dangerous
man when you're trying to make sure you
protect sources information
so I was told a few months ago that if
Stargate doesn't happen in the early New
Year in 2023 it won't happen for years
um
Amazon were already sort of like
apparently there was a marketing meeting
a couple of months ago and the marketing
team were going well let's announce that
we're doing something that's the good
news it'll be really good for MGM plus
and they were told very clearly you
can't because we're not 100 certain
we're doing it yet
and if we don't do it if it won't happen
for it'll it'll be completely put on the
backbone
so we've got close
is this just enough of a spot I mean My
Hope Is they come back in the new year
and then they go you know what how about
8 million
see my view on it is
Malkin Hawk they put in the work they
did the show Bible
they put in a lot of work before
speaking to Amazon essentially yeah
they then got the gig
and this is just a bump in the road
they're not going to have wanted to have
done all that work prior just for them
to say yeah we can't do it on that
budget and they go okay that's fine we
won't do it again they'll work something
I've got I've that's that's how I feel
they're going to have to work something
out so if it was me though if I was my
previous I'd be looking at what happened
with the expanse
where you are there the limited budget
and they were never allowed to produce
the show maybe they wanted to produce
and they were constantly able to do it
on a shoestring
maybe they're looking at it going I
don't want to do that again
and they proved themselves where they
shouldn't have to as well you know that
they have legitimately
made great franchises that people follow
and adore and
different streaming services are
fighting for as your video was talking
about yesterday
uh you know they need to actually have
what they have put
down put out there so I guess saying
that though they made the Bible but they
don't own the Bible do they Amazon owns
the Bible that they made right they only
like pee so yeah the Bible was just a
um like a guide for whoever was going to
make the show this is yeah
I'm just I guess assuming contractually
that even though that they wrote the
Bible that it was in the contract or
whatever they did sign is like okay
Amazon were by paid to do that yeah so
yeah everybody was bought
what I heard initially was though that
they did a lot of the Bible off their
own backs
um and then Amazon went oh that's a
that's this is great and then a deal was
signed for that and then um there was
some they've already been paid
apparently for some development work
because I mean no company does these
things for free do they so they would
have been paid for that but at the end
of the day it doesn't matter because the
content of the Bible is Stargate and
they own it this is like doing fan
fiction isn't it you have to be it's
there's such a
a fine line between what you can and
can't do
you know all these guys doing Star Trek
videos on um on YouTube some would argue
much better videos than um Discovery but
um uh much better content
but they have to be so careful because
if they cross the line they get sued and
the video gets taken down and they get
sued and then a couple of companies have
done
so but but yeah so basically even though
they own the Bible Amazon own what the
Bible says if that makes sense yeah that
makes perfect sense so I guess that
makes me follow up with another question
if they do want to go the the only like
positive I can see coming out of this
which is just spitballing it's it's
throwing spaghetti at a wall and hoping
it sticks you know if
they do want this smaller budget they're
willing to and they want to go to epics
they want to do all this stuff but they
they have the Bible that Mark and Hawk
wrote that they really like
could they take Brad right back because
he's willing to work within a smaller
budget a lot of the times and say hey we
like this story that Mark and Hawk did
better it fits within the world you
created can you come over here and meld
around what
was going to be and put it into a
smaller budget something that we can
actually work with with what we want to
do I'd rather than take the bigger
budget and go with Mark and Hawk and
maybe include Brad as a as a as a
producer co-show Runner whatever you
know as a
as a pundit or a host you know what I
mean uh but if that were to be the case
where Brad would actually come in here
and
be able to do it for a lot less
does that reopen the doors in any way or
is that just with speculation because we
have no idea
um but I mean you could argue that does
this just basically put us back to
square one and so anything's possible I
fear though if we go back to square one
they'll just Amazon to say well we're
concentrating on other things now
they're you know this left away
and we're gonna remember as well the the
state of streaming services right now
um
everywhere is cutting budgets I mean
look at what's going on with HBO max
they're cutting projects left right and
Center I'm doing a video shortly of
basically a list of projects that
are still stuck in development help and
it goes on and on and on the portal
movie sliders reboot
um Battlestar Galactica series and movie
um uh oh the the list just goes on and
on a project that would looked 12 months
ago to be nailed down and now you're
like where are they what's going on
is Stargate gonna just end up falling
into that category now of just projects
that you just think you know what we
love it
Babylon five we love it we just can't
afford it right now
well okay that makes me ask another
question why do you think they wanna
with the streaming service kind of war
the way it is at the moment it's kind of
dying out it's in its Third Leg I guess
we're we're all deciding what we're
gonna keep and not uh
why why do you think Amazon wants to do
all this with epics and MGM plus why
start a third streaming service instead
of really honing in on Amazon Prime
where anybody who pays for Amazon
already has that that doesn't
logistically make all that much sense to
me
yeah
it doesn't with me either which is why
nobody expected it everyone expected and
I think we did when we've talked about
it more than once
that when a new Stargate series came it
would go on Prime
because it's going to be an expensive
main project you know this was this was
talking about the um a tent pole project
sort of thing this is going to be
something that they
had other this was going to be our
franchise you know that they wanted to
push Star Trek for it's not going to be
that if it's on MGM Plus
there aren't enough subscribers and
there never will be and and Prime I
think their thinking is
Prime will become like this hub
so her prime won't really be a streaming
service
as much as a place to go to get
streaming services so it'll be that
place where you go and you buy you get
Netflix through Prime you get Disney
through Prime sort of thing which a lot
of people already do a lot of people you
know they get their Fire Sticks and they
get then they get private and then MGM
plus would just be like that it would
just be another
service do you get through that but the
thing is and and I say and you pay for
Prime because you get the free delivery
people almost don't see it like I got I
had prime for years and I never watched
it I paid for it because of the delivery
but they're moving away from that I have
noticed the stuff costs more in Prime
now because they just build the delivery
cost into the price instead of
and then you know and tell you to free
delivery and it's not but anyway that's
another another story
um but I think that's what they're
thinking and I think they think epics
that they they don't think of prime as a
stream and service
they think of it as a delivery service
for streaming services so less and less
stuff will necessarily appear on Prime
it'll be where you've got movies and you
pay for movies and things like this but
then but but I think it won't work
no that that makes me want to bang my
head up against the wall because the
next question I have is then why not
spend more money on Stargate for epics
to really attract some people it's just
there's there's that's exactly what I
was saying to begin with I want to start
with the bang
yeah
maybe it's a negotiation tactic maybe
Amazon uh just going right can you do it
for this we'll do it for this and
they're just trying to you know think
but I I don't know these things work
normally but I'm telling you what from
what I'm told Mark Fergus was
experienced when he left that meeting
it is what I'm told no no they were
getting into sort of
a blurry area of people's opinion and
you know whatever
um and then my focus isn't here to
defend himself but apparently it was it
was not a pleasant thing so
don't know about that we can we can
speculate on that but um yeah
the thing that annoys me about it all
right
Amazon has lots of money
so much
so much money
maybe not Amazon like the streaming
service side of it but the Amazon the
e-commerce side Amazon web hosting uh
web web servers things like that Amazon
has an entire company has so much money
just put some money into just just pull
it out of there an extra like
five million an episode or something you
could do it and it wouldn't even [ __ ] it
wouldn't even be a drop in the bucket
I mean we've we've talked about it
before they have the best Marketing
System that anyone could ask for that's
why the rings of power was so so viewed
even though not everybody loved it it
was so well viewed because everybody
that ordered an Amazon box for a couple
months got something with rings of power
on it why don't they do that with
the when sound of metal came out that
was an Amazon original why don't they do
that when a new season of
any of their other Originals comes out
maybe they do it with the expanse why
didn't they do with the experience
marvelous Miss major
boys look crazy
they've advertised the boys on like
actual like adverts but never I've never
seen it on packaging I like Amazon
packages all the time most genius most
simple way to do it too
the boys is a funny show isn't it
because it's an 18 is that the sort of
thing you want to stick on labels and
packages I'm not so sure but um but you
can also specify there's algorithms that
are I guess I it depends if it coming
from a warehouse or if it's coming from
an individual Amazon Seller I guess at
that point
where if you knew the product was 18
plus put it on there or 16 plus 14 plus
even you know uh because it's
technically tb14
but it was a TV mature I think it's TV
mature you might want to have to do 17
or 18 there
can you guys either of you guys think of
another TV show that's not on our
screens at the moment that people love
from Orphan Stargate I know we talk
about it all the time because we this is
we've become almost a Stargate Channel
but you know uh just one second
got a good name
must change my name uh just perspective
Misfits a semi-current show with great
right and sci-fi with a few VFX here and
there's 400k per episode so hey
I've not seen this oh have I seen The
Misfits is Misfit are you all about
Misfits the British one
the British television show where
they've all got super hot super powers
years ago
in 2021 with Pierce Brosnan and Tim Roth
I don't know oh that's a movie though
that's a movie Misfits TV series British
sci-fi comedy drama on e4 I don't that
that won't even be in the same ballpark
but I get where he's coming from
um
I I do I do get where he's coming from
but um
yeah
I think that's in this group
level of production value so I thought
of CGR of everything we are just scale
you know it's just like Doctor Who
Doctor Who cost a million two million
dollars an episode I mean they're
looking at massively increase in the
budget for Doctor Who
um Chris next year well this year and
you can see on the screen that it's like
two million dollars that they don't
spend a fortune on it
um
but
yeah I mean I remember years ago BBC did
a show space Precinct and it was the
first ever show British show to make
just cost a million dollars an episode
that he completely bombed
um but you could still tell it didn't
have the production value of Star Trek
that was running at the time or or
anything else but
um but yeah obviously again is there any
other sci-fi franchise that isn't in
production at the moment that's loved as
much as Stargate
I can think of
maybe if you have to get as much people
talk about as much with maybe Firefly
yeah
only thing I can think of is like a
Terminator but then again James
Cameron's always toying with people
about that even though they probably
shouldn't do anymore but
uh his most recent thing was though they
are working on a hard reboot apparently
talks are in
a happening who's going to be the
Terminator though because you cannot you
cannot replace Arnold Schwarzenegger you
just can't do it well he said he can't
do it with Arnold again because Arnold
was the reason dark fate didn't do well
in his opinion yes it's a too many
geriatrics
um
in the same league I love Babylon five I
don't think it's quite the same limit as
the league of Stargate I don't think
it's talked about as much as Stargate
the Orville is coming back to another
series they're just doing all the
negotiation stuff at the moment it's
definitely getting a fourth season I'm
told and Firefly
firefight they keep trying to bring back
um Disney the last thing I heard was
Disney just can't bloody figure out how
to do it
they want to bring it back they just
can't figure out how to do it and not
piss everyone off it's like do we do a
hard reboot do we do a continuation do
we and then just can't make their minds
up so
um and I don't think Farscape even
though I've got a video about Farscape
coming up quite soon
I don't think that's in the same league
as Target either
I completely agree with you but that's
just an example of some of the decent oh
low end of a budget yeah I know 100 I
could completely see where you're coming
from I just hope they don't do that
because
well look one of the things about
Stargate first couple of series
I mean you look back at them now I mean
Harris you've watched them recently they
don't have the production value of later
series I I actually watched some of the
special effects of even Seasons eight
nine and ten now and I watched a couple
of episodes recently then I'm looking at
some of the special accent camera that's
not great
um some of them are iffy there we go
yeah but it's a TV show 24 episodes a
year you know it's a completely
different world we live in there
but would we want a series that was just
Stargate that was more character driven
and cost a lot less money because at the
end of the day actors standing in front
of a green screen talking is cheaper
than spaceships flying around in blah
blah blah so could we
put up with
a more character-driven show if it meant
it cost less and I'd love to say yes but
you said you said it earlier sg1 was
costing a million dollars an episode I
don't know how early seasons were but if
it wasn't anywhere
this season was limited to nine hundred
thousand dollars an episode
at that point if they even want to get
in that same ballpark
I I wasn't alive at the time or I was
just being born but I can tell you just
from the past five or ten years A dollar
is not what it used to be I assume a
euro is not what it used to be a pound's
not what a pound used to be etc etc you
know so
per dollar that they're spending on this
they're not getting as much that does
mean they need more money and as much as
I I hate to be the person be like go
grab more money go grab more money focus
on the story it's story and characters
first and foremost always but if you
can't make a show that has a certain set
of expectations under it and you can't
meet those expectations
we're they won't get a season two they
won't get a second movie
so I think Stargate was always
mostly character driven the special
effects were secondary to for me a lot
of the time yeah yeah in later seasons
and special effects were pretty decent
like you could see the spaceships and
stuff they were cool but the story uh
and the character relationships was
always the best thing I mean the best
example I can give for Stargate the
two-part special Heroes
and I'm assuming you've seen Harris I'm
pretty sure you have there's literally
the only special effect I can see from
that episode was when Janet got shot for
buy stuff last
that entire thing was like a fake
documentary thing which they could have
filmed on like just a regular old camera
it was literally just story driven and
it's one of the best episodes of
Stargate
yeah and and you make a good point where
that is literally they only use VFX
where it's necessary to enhance the
story
yeah
in reality wasn't it always supposed to
be based in reality so basic reality
it's cheaper than
Star Trek yes where you have to build
massive expensive sets for everything
you have to use CGI for everything
whereas Stargate
look at this planet doesn't it look like
a forest in Northern California or
a quarry a sound Quarry the good things
Target never had was
like these a lot of sci-fi shows do it
with like these big establishing shots
of planets like they're very Fantastical
planets that we've never seen before
like like Star Wars for example you see
like the planet before you go onto it
I guess the reason we never see it is
because it's a Stargate and you're going
through that but
even when they're on ships and stuff you
never just see the planet first and then
it like pans down or anything like that
you don't have to worry about that kind
of like that kind of effect
because that was never part of it to
begin with
so I guess the Devil's Advocate that
just a little bit because I I do I mean
that's the perfect example of when they
use VFX lightly can they go back and do
that again though because that was what
season seven uh season eight maybe
that's still early on compared to what
they did with VFX at the end of su1 not
what they did with F I can't even speak
now VFX and SGA and I assume SGU is
taking place in Space the whole time can
they go back to that
is that even applicable I guess even
then the sets are so expensive these
sets cost a fortune to build
you know it's just like
that was one of the things about why
they wanted to sort of run the movies
and the TV series hand in hand and have
them crossed over so that they could
actually save a bit of money
and you know
um that's one of the reasons why you
know
Marvel try and do it is because it's
really status
because we're thinking oh yeah well it's
it is a very effective way of doing a
business model no but you have a big
franchise and you can but
ah sorry baby I've ruined his day room I
do I got the email
um
sorry baby
sorry baby
she says I've talked to my wife
um but um hey baby
um but yeah it ruined my day as well
um
it's
I just feel like it's um it's not it's
not the end they have a good working
relationship these negotiations can go
on
I just want to give you a warning my
source said the negotiations are have
collapsed and that was the word they
used so that doesn't sound like they're
very confident
that it's going to move forward it might
mean Amazon going a different direction
which is what we're all terrified of
with Bad Robot
um
I don't I don't know where we I I I I'm
just I'm just I got this this email to
me I can't tell you I've got it out but
um I think something we
should probably
stay as well come from this come from
one person well it comes from someone
they could be wrong
because we've about it in the past where
someone's mentioned like Brad writes in
an office blah blah that was wrong and
and it's come out
um
yeah I will show the source with you a
bit later um because obviously I didn't
want it I wanted your honest reaction
we're coming to the video
um they're not wrong
was it an honest enough reaction Jay now
that you've demonstrated
at the time we had the Brad right thing
we said he's in a meeting actually the
guy was telling me that even that was
correct there was a bunch of meetings
about Brad Wright unfortunately my store
she no longer talks to me because I
basically called him a liar in the video
afterwards
um uh just saw a bloke and he just
assumed so he made a genuine mistake
that was a mistake
um but you know the [ __ ] happens
in this respect it's it's not incorrect
the only thing we have to do is we have
to remember that we have to there's we
don't know everything
we we I keep saying like so we get
snapshots of information and it's
littered with people's opinion as well
which is also we've got to be very
careful we make sure we repeat and I I
think I have done a couple of times in
the video this is based on this guy's
opinion
[Music]
um
we have a snapshot of the information
that he's gone in there's been this
meeting
we know I know certain things that were
said that I can't share because it would
expose the source which nobody wants
Source exposed
um and but this is the gist of what what
the result was
um
and they were supposed to be other
meetings that day and they got canceled
which is also not a good sign
um
so
perhaps
a pause it could be a pause no as you
say things probably got a little bit
heated
they obviously weren't happy with the
conclusion they probably canceled the
meetings just to give everyone a bit of
a bit of a break
that's always a possibility
combat Refreshers think about it let's
come back in the New Year sort of thing
yeah holiday season right now
yeah I mean for me
five million dollars an episode is is
not enough they would they need to
negotiate for that
um or I would be happy if Amazon said
right for the first series you got 50
million dollars what can you do and if
four ghost B1 goes back and says
we can do six episodes
great do it
get something on our screen
get Amazon to have a look at it get them
to then decide right
yeah okay we've got our confidence or
just to go you know we put this in MGM
plus another bugger watched it but then
we ran it on Prime afterwards and
everybody watched it and everyone went
nuts let's do 10 episodes let you know
let's get this out just do something
tell them well this is what they did
with that um Witcher TV show recently
they they were supposed to do six
episodes everything sort of went a bit
sideways they just went well look we can
get four
so they did four
yeah that's that's that's one of the
things with stream of Sims is you can do
that
um it's not like the same like we've got
it's got 22 Episodes because you've got
to do 22 Episodes to fit the calendar
for the for the network
um and here's 100 million dollars do it
that that's they don't do that with
streaming services so
I just
so so yeah let's hope that this is an
ongoing negotiation and this is just a
hiccup along the way
um
how would you guys feel though if
like I say the rumors about Bad Robot
are true we we don't we don't know a lot
about those rumors we know very very
little all I know is for certain that
there is it was Stargate related and
there's some sort of contractual thing
going on
I will say though before we get into the
Bad Robot thing bad row but do currently
have an exclusive contract with Warner
Brothers
yeah now that exclusive contract looks
like it's on slightly dodgy ground
because the rumors are almost everything
that's on that slate is about to get
canceled
which might mean that contract is up for
you know some negotiation
um
but if Brad right if if sorry if this if
this Cuts canceled now and bad robot
step in
is that the end of the world
it's still Stargate
see I I want to say that but I tried to
use because I never grew up as a Star
Trek fan I try to use Bad Robot Star
Trek to get into Star Trek look how well
that panned out I I did the same
[Laughter]
time
I love Star Wars
yeah
I I just can't do those movies from the
fourth people people forgive Force
awakens but that is the root of the core
issue I cannot stand any of those three
films and and there are good bits of all
of them there really are really good
bits in all three of them
but the execution was was just not there
and I I primarily put that on
maybe some heads up over in Disney and
Star Wars and lucasfilm in general but
primarily on Bad Robot I I would not I
don't know
I throw a bit of Fringe yep
see I loved Fringe Fringe was amazing
bad robots one of those things that when
I did the video last week I said just
just before you have I get an
instinctual dear God no go back and have
a look at actually what they've done
because they've done some great TVs and
some great movies I love the first
Cloverfield film I thought it'd be great
and I thought it was so clever and they
produced that you know it's like they've
done some good stuff let's hope they
could maybe revert to that and do
something
those those are all Original Stories
aren't they of their good stuff are
mostly Original Stories where they are
bad reboot
it's just yeah ah
yeah that's true that's true oh they
also did Westworld Westworld the first
season West was brilliant that it was
amazing and then it just
yeah not so much I don't watch it
anymore
I still haven't seen season four and I
watched season three and was like okay
there's I can see what they're doing I I
couldn't I I left it yeah
oh God's plan it's just like Cloverfield
[ __ ] I loved the first Cloverfield the
second Cloverfield yeah the third
Cloverfield I think there's there's a
third one
and there's a fourth one coming I think
I'm hoping it's canceled that's part of
the Warner Brothers deal
because our first one was clever but
just forever God don't do nothing it's
clever because you never actually see
what's going on and I quite enjoy that
way of doing it but you don't need to
make any more that's well done don't do
it again
sort of situation but they keep doing it
again oh that made money and it didn't
cost much to make let's let's do nine
let's do nine
well yeah so that's where we're at at
the moment just anyway so
Happy New Year
happy New Year Stargate fans I
will say that the only thing I'm really
confident on right now is that we won't
be getting an announcement anytime soon
it seems to me it's really disappointing
I was
very lucky I I've
had it in my mind January
so January to April we're gonna get
something and I've been looking forward
to it
now
to give you a little bit of a sweet
release of death
sweet release of Ascension
I can always come back if they do if
they do I can do it
um
one positivity I I did get out of the
person I spoke to because one of those
people I speak to is very much in the
legal side of things and this was months
ago they told me this but they're saying
but a lot of the time these shows they
go through all of this and this is and
he said to me at the time prepare for a
roller coaster because this is going to
be a [ __ ] nightmare
um it's too big a project and
everything's a bit of a mess right now
so it's going to be a roller coaster and
but then he says but these things they
happen like that
there's this or you think nothing's got
nothing and then all of a sudden
there'll be one meeting somebody with
actually the authority to go let's do it
we'll we'll stamp a bit of paper and
then all of a sudden it's all go so we
could go from literally thinking oh this
is dead to an official announcement in
no time
and it'll simply because somebody with
some Authority has gone let's just do it
you know and that's the way it works
so I mean that's why I mean like
God of War right that was in development
for ages I knew about God of War I knew
Mark Fergus was involved with God in war
in February or March
and they only announced it last week or
two three weeks ago
wow hmm you know it's like Henry Cavill
um with his new project and with
Warhammer that's been talked about we
now know for ages
and we thought that's what he was
leaving The Witcher to go to do Superman
and then look how quickly that just went
from you're doing Superman you're not
doing Superman and quickly that that
just completely spun in its head
so well
that kind of begs the question does same
thing how God of War kind of it takes
Mark Ferguson hawkheartsby away a little
bit from Stargate in a way and and it
might complicate making it to a degree
does warhammered complicate making it to
a degree because they're really just
looking for their big sci-fi franchise
and if they're not using the expanse if
the stargate's looking dicey for them
they've already announced Henry Cavill
as is he is he a showrunner or just
executive producer I think he's uh he'll
be the executive producer and stuff
um then with Warhammer they don't have a
they don't have a showroom or a
production company yet okay but with
something like that that has 30 plus
years of lore Stargate has nearly 30 but
Warhammer has even more so it has a
built-in fan base maybe just as big we
we don't really know because it's
tabletop and it kind of it's hard to
skew those numbers probably but
all right now on the loads of Novel I'm
not a big I don't follow Warhammer I've
never got into these games but I have no
idea all sorts of games and there's
loads and loads of Lords that's up to
base on it looks badass it looks awesome
but or what is that one of the reasons
they're not
pushing Stargate because all right well
now we have Henry Cavill under our backs
people are people want to see them
people are pissed off he's not Superman
people are pissed off he's not Witcher
we've got this built-in audience because
Henry Cavill is himself a huge draw
okay
Warhammer is another big wrong as well
but he's come out of everything that's
happened in the last couple of months
even more popular isn't it I mean yeah
people think like all of a sudden this
guy is not just a great actress that
goes well he's a massive geek he loves
him he left the Witcher because of where
they were taking it so he's got is
somebody with um morals and you know
that he yeah he he he's like us he wants
things to stick to Canon and he wants
things to be you know um true to the
source material so I mean Geeks are just
like he's the ultimate geek and look at
him he can get women we all want to be
him all of a sudden like every geek on
the planet wants to be Henry Cavill it's
um I think we always knew is a nice guy
because there's never been any [ __ ]
about him but now it's just everybody
loves him so well I think I'm like Henry
Cavill
Henry Cavill
no I I get people coming up and going
Henry no oh sorry no no no no that's
okay it's an objects look the same right
you know yeah yeah but anyway guys
that's the news so I thought we'll end
the show just having a quick chat about
2023
um
before we do that I was going to say
there is an announcement there is 193
people in here right by the way I don't
know if you've noticed
we did today which is amazing guys thank
you so much very very amazing
um so in that in that uh vein
we have an announcement
here it is nine chevrons.com
is your dedicated source for Stargate
news which will aim to complement this
YouTube channel with news that we have
from our contacts at MGM and Amazon
breaking news about a new potential
Stargate series as well as providing
reviews and any potential updates to new
stories that we break check out some of
the news articles that we have already
at nineshavrons.com
okay let's go
oh my God the one thing the most
chevrons.com I mean I don't know about
you man but I would absolutely love it
if the guy's watching if they ever want
to submit
um any stories that we could put online
showbox.com with Mom will I write a fair
bit of it I'm writing one at the moment
about all this crap we've been talking
about today
um but anybody ever wants to put in
reviews what they love about
like that you know we really want it to
be a community page don't we as much as
anything else so there is a there is a
contact page on there and there's also
forums as well so you can join the
community create an account post
whatever you want if you want to share
something specifically that you want to
see on the site head over to the contact
page it's on the about nine Chevrons and
you'll see your pictures of me Harris
and Jay and stormy just scroll down a
bit and then you can contact us it's a
picture of Matt just to make sure that
you don't get confused with that all
right so
um throw up the other advert and then
we'll talk about 2023.
get yours today and show your support at
SCI dashtrack.com
look at this acting like an actual
YouTube channel
hey this wants to be much I hate my day
job I want this to be my job I would
love to just sit around talking about
Stargate all day so um we have to make
money to be able to do that I know I'm
afraid because my wife won't let me so
um
it doesn't make enough money you can't
quit your job oh but if I quit my job
I'd be able to put more effort in and
then I'd make more money so
quick quick but anyway you know as you
guys before we call it an evening
um I'd love to I'd like to say I was
supposed to be looking up what I was
looking forward to for 2023 but then all
this [ __ ] kicked off so I have no clue I
haven't looked I'm not gonna lie so
um guys what what are you looking
forward to and guys get into the
comments as well what sort of things are
you looking forward to for 2023 we're
looking forward to in a year 2022 by the
way guys with [ __ ] let's hope for a
better 2023
I've got six six shows I'm actually
looking forward to
so we're at five don't don't pick one
you're not gonna stop the numbers I'm
just sitting with it come on
so apparently apparently I didn't notice
but apparently stranger things coming
back this year but I thought it was next
year so if it's this year I'm looking
forward to that I was told yeah I was
told 2015 20 25 so but yeah
yeah well I'm looking forward to the
Umbrella Academy that's coming back this
year
um Doctor Who that's the big one
Doctor Who 60th anniversary special is
going to be three episodes and we're
gonna get something at Christmas I'm so
looking forward to that Harris don't
watch Umbrella Academy when you're
you're taking your recreational
I think you want to be stoned watching
them what do you think I've done for the
first three seasons I'm ready
but we've also got Mandalorian coming
out season three and
um
uh a new season of Loki
you two will know but to the viewers
watching this I quickly looked up new
shows coming out in 2023 before the live
show
saw Loki and actually went
because I was so excited Oh I thought
you were electrocuted
I like to give myself but low-key season
two yeah I I can't wait to see where
they're going to go with it my
confidence levels though are like that
high right now about anything in my
mouth will do because I just they just
keep they just keep [ __ ] everything
up so um let's see what they do but
nothing uh in the comments actually guys
said Star Trek Picard series three
I am cautiously I've been talking a lot
to the um I keep calling them Pop Tarts
they annoyed me last week the podcast
chaps
um they did a video and basically saying
everything that we've been saying and
didn't reference me and I was just I was
pissed off
um so I contacted them and they went
yeah I was sorry we actually thought you
were full of [ __ ] but now we realize
you're not and they were very very nice
about it and then they tweeted that
sidetracks are awesome and really really
nice so I actually tweeted him in it
popped up fuckwards
so I better not call them pop dance but
anyway they're actually really lovely
guys I was talking to Shane and he's
really lucky guy
um he is very confident that Star Trek
Picard Series 3 will not let us down it
will absolutely be good and that we
should be real it really is a nice way
to say goodbye to these characters
so
and my confidence levels after Picard
series one and two are that big it's
like I think episode will probably be
brilliant in the rest of the season well
either make no [ __ ] sense or just
generally be born and [ __ ] so let's see
what happens I know you guys aren't big
star trekkies but actually
card coming back for me is a big deal
the first series was the most I was the
most excited I I actually looked like
I've been electrocuted several times
you're making that same noise
um I can't see it was too they got me
again they hooked me I was oh
[ __ ]
um
so
fingers crossed fingers crossed gamer
beans The Last of Us yes I've seen the
evidence in the next two weeks
doesn't it doesn't it uh next week or
week after
it's I want to say the 14th and the 17th
or the two dates that come to mind one
or the other maybe not one's about right
to me but but yeah I think that looks
very interesting it's going to be on Sky
over here in the UK so assume it's a HBO
show is it I I haven't really looked it
up but it does look interesting
oh yeah I never played the game but the
story is supposed to be phenomenal this
game is good I love the game yeah yeah
and you get a PlayStation how about you
how much what are you looking forward to
sir well now that you're talking about
TV shows coming out this month
I I'm I'm old near and dear to Star Wars
of course and Star Wars the bad batch
season two airs in two days it starts in
two days so a little Star Wars animation
I'm a happy camper there uh you know I
told you I was printing out the Rotten
Tomatoes list of the 35 best films of
the year so that's what I was running to
do a minute ago
my printer ran out of paper before it
even got to the first page so we thought
that was beeping we heard beeping that
might have been some beeping right there
uh but besides that
I guess just while we mentioned Marvel a
second ago because I'm I'm really not
excited for anything they're doing maybe
a little bit for the Daredevil show Echo
I'm intrigued about if blade comes out
somehow possibly this year which it's
not like you know I'm not going to I I
am looking forward to that but the one
thing that actually has kind of caught
my eye I I guess Guardians 3 could be
good
not over it at this point but that the
the holiday special didn't really grab
my attention as much as I would have
liked it to I would have rather it been
a little more grounded than fun and and
not childish but childish I guess
I'm excited for quantumania Ant-Man
quantumania that trailer just it hits
the Sci-Fi and the fantasy kind of nerd
in me and that actually and I think Paul
Rudd is a very clever man apparently
when he went in to do
um the first one he said the script was
[ __ ] and they basically spot the
negotiations they allowed him to mess
around with the script and fix it and he
apparently a few people in Kevin fire
you said this film was saved by Paul Rod
so I actually think he's very clever and
I think the first two have been great
so yeah there are Diamonds in the Rough
mm-hmm
but besides that though I guess there is
a little sci-fi coming out I'm excited
for 65 that new Adam Driver and Sam
Raimi movie uh
if I'm if I'm going through here I I
know do number two is coming out this
year and the second Dune I'm ecstatic
for it uh
you you haven't watched it I loved the
first one it's a certain point we've got
to do I didn't think the movie was
coming out this season the another TV
series is
I think both Dunes no it says November
of this year I believe okay
but then there's also that new Hunger
Games movie which piques my interest I
don't know if I have confidence in it or
not but it Peaks my mind I've missed
that oh The Ballad of strong virgin
snakes
okay
I have to admit it's not massively high
up on my
um priority list
um but I I enjoyed the movies
as much as I could I I sort of punched
through in the same sort of category as
I enjoyed what's that Bloody vampire
film with Robert Patterson and smell the
[ __ ]
Twilight Twilight it's in that sort of
category for me films I quite enjoy but
I really shouldn't publicly say it
so um it's it's a bit like that for me
which one
both from Twilight and Hunger Games oh
I like it Hunger Games never watched it
it just didn't look interesting I like
Hunger Games but I'll have to judge it
just a little bit frequently it's a
he-man live action movie stuff supposed
to be out this year on Netflix
that might be the thing I'm most excited
about
let me just look very quickly
live action movie I know this summer we
got some good stuff though the new
Indiana Jones movie which I'm iffy about
but James mangold's great so I I have
faith in his directing but then the new
Mission Impossible see okay I saw that
is Mission Impossible just gonna take
out Indiana Jones are we going to get
Adventures that's going to denigrate the
Harrison Ford Adventures you know like
uh just a thought but Oppenheimer is
right after that and those three look
fantastic in their own rights I've
watched moonfall it was Bloody awful but
I have to admit I enjoyed how Bloody
older was foreign
until this year but I can't wait for
that live-action humor
um
I was gonna say something else then I
forgot what it was
um
Moon Falls distracting yeah I was
distracted by the whole Moon four thing
I saw that in IMAX with Roland Emery
like presenting it and doing a talk
afterwards and there was 15 people in
the entire IMAX movie theater it was so
fun it was too bad but it was so fun
because you know I choked right before
it so that was that was a great mindset
to be in there your career is over who
said that
this [ __ ] get out
on the way out yeah what it felt like it
was it was it was yeah it was it was
pretty bad
um but but in a lovable kind of way it
wasn't
um the
um Independence Day two Independence Day
bad that was just bad
at least it was it was a fun but
um yeah yeah I think we've got some
interesting projects this year I think I
think 2023's got the opportunity to be a
good year
my only concern is that 2020 was [ __ ]
2021 was [ __ ] in 2022 with [ __ ] so
let's open complaints they say it comes
in threes so cool
some diamonds sometimes we've had some
diamonds in the last couple of years we
have had some amazing projects hey
the Super Mario movie can do one thing
you're right do you know what a lot of
the um things oh no I don't remember
what I was gonna say remind me I
remember
the Super Mario movie though apparently
all of the like the the the the the
early views of people apparently have
been really really positive and people
have loved it oh I expect it to be
really good I've if it's if I don't love
it I expect to absolutely love it
um
that's the only reason I want to see you
because
people are angry about Chris Pratt but
he's doing a little bit more of a New
York voice which is how Mario started so
like if you go back to the old old games
work for New York then it was uh it
exasperated Italian and you don't want
to hear an exasperated like
characterized Italian man for two and a
half hours that would be
so I I don't know I I think it's going
to end up pretty good I have some news
on sliders I was asked about this by um
a comment earlier and I've asked around
a little bit I know a little bit about
that but I will do it in a video when I
get time I'll tell you about sliders
Indiana Jones I have had a little bit of
things so um I'll speak to one of the
people I do speak to and it's not sci-fi
so I haven't done a video on it because
I couldn't be I well it's over Christmas
and I couldn't be bothered but
apparently
um
it's not going well
and they're they're just they've done
early screenings and even though the
film is supposed to be out shortly
they've done one lot of reshoots
um and they are planning another set of
reshoots
and it is possible that
um it might even get pushed back yet
um but apparently people hated the end
so bad they actually shouted abuse
in some of the viewings and you know
some of these early viewings are like a
lot of these guys are professional
people actually this they actually get
paid to go and watch these movies and
then never tell anybody and you know and
then give their honest opinion for them
to actually get physically angry
is apparently very unusual
um
so
Richard said something in the comments
he said Indiana Jones 5 is too tiny
whimey that is my biggest hang up on it
because you just said it's not sci-fi
but it kind of is now that there are
aliens and everything Shia LaBeouf and
everything from the fourth one I know
they're not gonna Pro they're hopefully
not gonna stick to that it's but if
they're going at a time travel right
next it's nice if puppies
running around the things in the last
round they got ridiculous I uh somebody
just mentioned that the Dungeons and
Dragons movie I've lost it
I'm actually quite looking forward to
that that looks fun but me I loved the
first one which is like a that's one of
those films it's God it's so bad
um but and um I forgot the main
protagonist in the act the British actor
that was the main bad guy it's so Camp
Jeremy Irons right you got me irons
that's the best parts I love that they
just went mate
go for it it's just it's just like
overacted the whole way through it was
oh God it was bad
um and one of the Wayans brothers was in
it and snails and he got stabbed and
nobody cared and but then his mate was
like no not proper no oh I dropped his
knees with a sword in it oh man it was
so bad it was glorious
um
I think it still looks fine that and and
someone commented cocaine bear earlier
that also looks like a lot of fun those
look like maybe the two most fun movies
of the year do you know that's one of
those films it's a bit like Snakes on a
Plane where you just know because
apparently that's actually rough isn't
it roughly based on a true story
emphasis roughly but probably yeah
um but snake I just love that there's a
story that snakes in a plane and got
green lit because somebody like I think
it was new line Cinema was in it they
basically went look what's the stupidest
title we've got on the list and this is
like the chief executive sort of thing
and then we've got this thing snakes in
a plane but it's really bad
let's do it who can we get to make it
Samuel Jackson's not doing anything
doing and that's how it got decided it's
literally one meeting where the guy went
let's just do something stupid
and this this cocaine Bears smacks of
that a bit to me someone's like they it
feels like at the end of a very long
meeting somebody went look we've got
some great moves here guys who have
worked really hard but Christ we've got
to do something to make us laugh
let's just do something
cocaine there done
the trailer is so good just the bear
doing the line off of that one dude's
leg is this is just the funniest thing
it's definitely gonna be one of those
films that you watch and just go what
did I just watch yeah but guys we're
gonna call it a day because I've got to
grab my tea and I'll I'm gonna catch up
I've been looking at my messages
regarding what's going on with Stargate
and I'm like
oh
I'll come back to you with any updates
as soon as I get them but um I I don't
think we'll hear anything now till the
new year
I got this news a week after it happened
so I was like come on if any of my
sources are watching sort it out I mean
for [ __ ] sake like
don't start a message with oh by the way
I forgot to tell you that the most
important thing that ever happened just
happened so shout out for Beacon 23 and
welcome out okay
I don't know about what we'll have to
Google it I know about beacon23 that
looks cool
bunk Bonk is still a great name though
on it
um I am gonna get a beer I'm I am going
I have decided with the Stargate news
I was disappointed I went through the
five stages of grief I was disappointed
I was scared I was angry I can't
remember what the fourth one is but then
I accepted it denial deny I denied it
it's not true
so my nose is really itching sorry
um but
I I'm going to hope that we'll hear
something else in a couple of weeks
that'll this is just a negotiation thing
and because I really really think Mark
Fergus is the guy to run this if we're
not getting Brad right Mark Fergus is
the guy so
we really have to hope that this is not
this is just a a bump in the road
and they can figure something out and if
Amazon is set on 50 million
Hawk has been said okay well how about
we do
the first half of the series and see
what see what the response is like and
you know just do five episodes or six
episodes and do something that's
worthwhile and then
you know they they adjust their plans
that's what I'm hoping but yeah
he's had his Christmas lunch maybe
there'll be a different maybe different
heads but I just I just know that all
the streaming services including Amazon
are so [ __ ] screwed right now
money-wise that it's like
that because three times and they'll
just be like well you can you can do it
now we'll give you the money it's fine
we've had our turkey
and uh
let's do star game
um hey but one of the things I will say
is share this video I will follow up and
I will get edits from the videos to
explain as quick as I can on the side
track Science Channel share them we we
and that's not just just I mean
obviously I wanted to advertise Side
Track remember the thing I mentioned
earlier about wanted to do this full
time
I need your money to do that and I need
views but more importantly actually for
me is we need to get people talking
about it because the more people that
talk about it the more Amazon are
watching
the more likely it is that they'll
come up with a solution
but they've got to do it Alex a welcome
to the soundtrack family sir thank you
very very much
um
uh so there's a few people going 50
million for what please just go back to
the start of the video you'll we explain
it all the first 10 minutes
um should we just do a quick recap for
the anybody that's watching now
yeah yes well tell me in the things if
you want to okay let's do a quick recap
so the sources that I speak to we know
that um Hawk Coast beat and Mark Fergus
is penguin and Parker company was
looking to do a new stargazes and the
contract negotiations had started I'm
being told that just before Christmas
um already energized a new member
thank you again hey everybody everybody
join everybody watching join right now
you can gift memberships to other people
as well just just to let you know
um so negotiations happen there was a
few stumbling box blocks very early on
so initially there was some doubts about
whether penguin and Parker could do it
because of the God of War project and
there were some voices within Amazon
that was saying um you know can you do
both are you big enough you got enough
experience
that was crushed quite quickly saying
that look Mark Fergus is going to run a
Stargate or Coast spear is going to run
God of War
fine there was in some timeline stuff
but I'm told by my source that that's
normal negotiation stuff the Amazon
Executives always want stuff I always
think it's like a Stargate Star Trek
sorry they've seen the thing about
um how the engineer always tells him it
takes four times longer to do anything
in Star Trek because then you get how
else do you get the reputation of being
a miracle worker it's almost like that
relationship like the that's the caption
the ship going we need this now and the
engineer going well you can get it in
six months no we want it in two months
okay maybe three and then then it makes
it look amazing so I don't know if it's
that sort of thing
the stumbling block was when they
started talking about the budget for the
series because this is going to appear a
current link this will currently appear
on MGM Plus
Amazon have said that is a smaller
platform and it's going to have a
smaller budget it'll still be the
biggest budget of any show on MGM plus
but a smaller budget of five million
dollars an episode or 50 million dollars
for 10 episodes when it works for
streaming is that you they can spend
some more on some episodes and some Less
in other episodes some episodes only
cost a couple of million but then big
CGI episodes might cost eight nine ten
million
um and that's how these things work
nowadays so
you know it's just like
I'm told hawcostby's number was around
100 220 million for 10 episodes and they
believe that was going to be the budget
I was told actually going back six
months when MGM still thought they were
going to make this but they were told
they were going to be allowed 10 to 12
million dollars an episode and that was
when Brad Wright was still involved so
that was the budget they were looking at
then which would have been around Star
Trek level Discovery costs on average 11
million an episode
that's the budget they were looking at
and now they're looking at less than
half of that
in a different climate where [ __ ] costs
more
that is
the end of it
um we obviously then we talked about the
stream of services and things I'm going
to get my tea and I might get a bit
drunk
I'll probably get a bit drunk
yeah I'm thinking
yeah
okay yeah we know what you're going to
do Harris
um but guys look so I really do want to
end a little bit of positivity though
this is a negotiation on a contract
if anybody's ever negotiated anything
like buying a new car you know the guy
selling the car is going to come in
because they don't want to spend money
they're going to go in low and then the
guy wanted to buy the cargo about this
about that you know I mean it's like so
this is a negotiation
there's still time hopefully this is
just a bump in the road let's see how it
goes all right but as soon as I know
anything as always I will get it to you
um I will put the full story
on
um
as soon as I can
um Matty will if that's shared on the
Facebook Channel and I will share the
night Chevron on the Community page as
well so you can read about that and you
can comment on it
um and I will follow up with
um other videos as soon as I learn more
all right guys
as always thank you for your time
that's all right you have no choice I'm
in charge and you do as you're told so
but it's still lovely that you've turned
up and Harris who
just
shut up
thank you so much for your time Mick I'm
sorry I didn't have better news for you
because I just I didn't tell you and
then I just got in uh Harris you know
all that thing you're really looking
forward to it's not happening
he talked about all the fun stuff coming
out for 2023 so we got stuff to look
forward to nonetheless right glass half
full something like that
everybody that has joined thank you so
much really the members
really do help support the channel and
thank you very very much
um and obviously if the people have
contributed through
um
um chats as well really appreciate it
and I guess so guys we had over 200
people watching today I'm alive which we
have never had before so instantly 200
for the entire time we were talking
about Stargate over 200. it was amazing
exactly
sexually transmitted disease well
someone just said where is it I seem to
remember people saying STD needing
constant reshoots which drove up its
budget Discovery Star Trek Discovery
Discovery okay I'm with you now
well that shows actually ended up being
it's kind of an STD I'll tell you what's
a bit of an STD show it gives you it
always makes me itch anyway I was so
confused for a second I was like what
are these people talking about in here
guys thank you so very much and we will
see you very very soon
um Matt when you put all the new things
on did you put the
um end bit on
nope you didn't so we're just gonna end
the video say bye-bye everybody
bye
see y'all
[Music]